.
* Hupen *
* Hämmernde Technobeats *
Welcher Stuhl ist für mich?
Du kannst wählen.
In vielen Köpfen
ist das Vorurteil zementiert,
ein Mensch mit Behinderung
ist abhängig, auf Pflege angewiesen
und lebt in einer Institution
und wird bevormundet.
Dass sie selbstständig sind, können
sich viele Leute nicht vorstellen.
(Durchsage) Gleis 7 ...
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
... Abfahrt 9.34 Uhr ...
Blitzgescheit, ehrgeizig, clever.
Er hat alles, was es
für eine Politkarriere braucht,
aber auch alles,
was sie verhindern kann.
Seine Behinderung,
die kosovarischen Wurzeln,
ja, selbst sein Vorname
ist ein Handicap.
Er heisst Islam, Islam Alijaj -
und will in den Nationalrat.
Die Geschichte beginnt in Zürich-
Albisrieden, Monate vor den Wahlen.
Bis heute ist bei der SP
nur eine Kandidatur eingegangen -
die von Islam, vielen Dank.
Vielleicht wäre es gut,
wenn wir von Islam noch mal hören,
warum er kandidieren möchte,
was seine Motivation ist.
Nachher könnten wir noch
das Empfehlungsschreiben durchgehen,
wenn das für euch okay ist.
Deine Visionen in einem Satz?
Im Empfehlungsschreiben steht:
Wir unterstützen Islam nicht,
weil er eine Behinderung hat,
ein Migrant und Muslim ist.
Aber eigentlich
schon auch ganz fest.
Wir wollen keine identity politics
machen, schreiben wir,
aber es ist schon ein mega Signal.
Mir ging das Gleiche durch den Kopf.
Ich verstehe,
weshalb wir das so schreiben
und sagen,
dass wir genau das nicht wollen.
Gleichzeitig wäre es mutig,
es umzukehren
und unsere Partei herauszufordern
und zu sagen,
dass sich genau diese Frage stellt.
Es verliert den politischen
Anspruch, wenn man sagt,
dass man kandidiere,
weil man eine Behinderung habe.
Dann: Wir unterstützen Islam nicht
n u r, weil er eine Behinderung hat.
Dann wäre das Problem
mit drei Buchstaben gelöst.
Es ist so:
Wenn Islam nicht Islam wäre,
würden wir nicht
so ein Bewerbungsschreiben machen.
Ich glaube, das wird spektakulär.
* Lachen *
Die erste Hürde hat er genommen.
Sie werden ihn der Stadtpartei
als Kandidaten empfehlen.
Islam ins Bundeshaus: Eine
Mission Impossible nimmt Fahrt auf.
(Islam) Go, go, go.
- Hier entlang?
Eine Frau mit Behinderung wird
grundsätzlich doppelt diskriminiert:
als Frau und zusätzlich
wegen der Behinderung.
Als ich 1992 in Geologie disser-
tieren wollte, bekam ich zu hören,
dass behinderte Frauen in der Wis-
senschaft nichts zu suchen hätten.
Barbara Müller
nimmt nie ein Blatt vor den Mund.
Seit 30 Jahren
erblindet sie mehr und mehr.
Seither kämpft sie für ihr Recht,
sein zu dürfen, was sie sein will:
Wissenschaftlerin.
Müller, hier Gastrednerin
einer ETH-Vortragsreihe,
erkämpfte sich den Doktortitel
gegen viele Widerstände.
Und noch heute
fühlt sich die Geologin
wegen ihrer Augenkrankheit
oft diskriminiert.
Wenn ein Mensch mit Behinderung
eine kognitiv hochqualifizierte
Arbeit macht,
geht das vielen Menschen
gegen den Strich.
Sie fühlen sich
im Selbstwert betupft.
Unter einem Menschen mit Behinderung
stellt man sich in der Regel
einen geistig Behinderten vor,
z.B. mit Trisomie 21.
Aber dass jemand auf universitärem
Niveau in der Schweiz forschen kann,
das geht vielen nicht in den Kopf.
Oder sie fühlen sich abgewertet.
Wer Barbara Müller vorschreiben will,
was und wie sie zu arbeiten hat,
muss sich warm anziehen.
Wenn es sein muss,
streitet die Thurgauerin mit Behörden
und Institutionen
bis vor Bundesgericht.
Mit Ihnen ist nicht gut Kirschen
essen, wenn es um die Geschich...
Nein. Wirklich nicht,
wenn es um diese Geschichten ...
Jetzt streiten wir seit 2004 über
den Beruf, den ich ausüben darf.
Laut IV Thurgau darf ich nicht
in der Wissenschaft tätig sein.
Ich müsste einer Umschulung zur
medizinischen Masseurin zustimmen.
Angeblich gibt es laut IV
sog. typische Blindenberufe.
Das geht bei ihnen immer
über die manuelle Fähigkeit,
das Tastgefühl.
Aber akademisch Gebildete
sind dort völlig unbekannt.
Die Mitarbeiter dort
sind selbst keine Akademiker.
Dann gibt es Probleme.
5'000 Seiten Akten,
17 Gerichtsverfahren,
die meisten davon gewonnen.
Fast immer geht es um Hilfsmittel,
die sie zum Arbeiten braucht.
Etwa eine Software, die ihr
geschriebene Texte vorspricht.
Oder dann gab es den Streit
um einen speziellen Blindenstock.
Der Laser-Langstock
würde 3'000 Fr. kosten,
ein Blindenhund,
der etwa acht Jahre im Einsatz ist,
weit über 60'000 Fr.
Die IV Thurgau kam zum Schluss,
dass der eine Luxusausführung sei.
Den zahlen sie nicht.
Aber einen Hund ...
- ... hätten sie gezahlt, ja.
Ich ging
vors Verwaltungsgericht Thurgau:
Selbstverständlich habe ich recht.
Anstelle eines Blindenhundes kann
ich die günstigere Variante haben.
Mit all den
bisherigen Gerichtsfällen
hat man mind. 250'000 Fr.
Steuergelder verschwendet.
Darüber muss man sich
im Klaren sein.
Unbeugsam und konsequent
fordert Barbara Müller ihr Recht ein.
Nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Komm, Kater, komm.
Komm, Fridtjof.
Komm zu mir.
* Elektronische Musik *
"God is a DJ", heisst es.
Bei Amir Gashi stimmt es sicher.
Er ist DJ DFKT X.
Die Muskelkrankheit begann,
als er sechs war,
nun bestimmt sie sein Leben.
Aber nicht diese Nacht.
Kopfhörer aufsetzen.
Amir legt mit Freund Livio auf,
als DJ-Kollektiv Das Hertz.
Heute bestimmt Amir Timing und Set.
Ich würde sagen, gegen 20.45 Uhr ...
Ja, genau.
Ja, Mann. Stell dir das vor!
Und dann kommt das Bellerive.
Auf Das Hertz.
Das Hertz, Mann!
* Die Musik dröhnt im Hintergrund. *
DJ DFKT X
ist bereit für die grosse Show.
* Harte elektronische Technomusik *
Amirs Krankheit
verschlimmert sich in Schüben.
Doch ans Aufhören
denkt er nicht mal im Traum.
Zu gross ist seine Leidenschaft
für Techno und harte Beats.
Es macht mir grosse Freude, und ich
kann meine kreative Ader ausleben.
Man kann etwas rauslassen.
Techno, relativ harter Sound.
Normalerweise sind wir härter
als an einem Festival.
Das ist vielleicht die Wut.
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Die muss raus.
In diesem Moment fühlt man ...
... dass die Tanzenden
den Sound feiern.
* Harte Technobässe *
Auftritte bringen Amirs Körper
an seine Grenzen.
Das muss er wegstecken.
Es zählt nur die Performance.
Ich mache nicht Musik,
weil es herzig ist.
* Treibende Bässe *
Nein, nein.
Er ist einer der besten DJs,
mit denen ich gearbeitet habe.
Er hat ein sehr akkurates
Sound-Verständnis.
Wie man vielleicht gerade mitkriegt!
Er ist der lebende Beweis dafür,
worum es geht.
Ich muss wieder rauf.
Er geniesst den Alltag,
umso mehr, weil er weiss,
dass er vielleicht nicht 80 wird.
80 wird er sowieso nicht.
Eher 35.
Etwas um das herum.
Aber daran wollen wir
nicht zu stark denken.
Kein Problem.
Für Amir Gashi
gibt es nur das Hier und Jetzt.
Als DJ wird er auflegen,
bis es nicht mehr geht.
* Verspielte Melodie *
* Islam lacht. *
Zu Hause bei den Alijajs.
Eine ganz normale Familie in Zürich.
Das könnte sich ändern, falls Islam
in den Nationalrat gewählt würde.
Islam Alijaj will für die SP
in den Nationalrat,
trotz schwerer
Körper- und Sprechbehinderung.
Oder gerade auch deshalb.
Tschau.
- Tschüss.
Heute muss sich Islam
den Genossinnen und Genossen
der Stadtpartei präsentieren.
Das macht ihm etwas Bauchweh,
denn seine Kandidatur
kommt nicht bei allen gut an.
Wir kommen zur Nominierung der
Nationalrats... bzw. zur Empfehlung.
Es ist kein Abend der Entscheidung,
aber eine Weichenstellung.
Islam Alijaj kennt nur ein Tempo:
Vollgas.
Er ist erst zwei Jahre in der Partei,
hatte noch nie ein politisches Amt
und will nun auf der Überholspur
direkt ins Bundeshaus.
Sehr keck für einen Newcomer
unter auch national bekannten
politischen Schwergewichten.
Grüezi. Badran.
Mit einer Rede begründet Islam
die Kandidatur noch einmal.
Und zwar so,
wie er es im Nationalrat tun würde:
mithilfe einer Verbal-Assistentin.
Gut.
Liebe Genossinnen, liebe Genossen.
Er will ein Bekenntnis,
kein Gratisticket.
Wer sich Inklusion
auf die Fahne schreibe wie die SP,
müsse auch einen wie ihn
nach Bern schicken.
Einige unserer Genossinnen
und Genossen haben das Gefühl,
dass ich
nur in diesem Thema bewandert
und ein Ein-Themen-Politiker bin.
Es wäre schön, wenn ich von euch
die Chance erhielte,
als erster Zürcher Volksvertreter
mit Behinderung
in Bern für eine inklusive Politik
einzustehen.
Besonders würde es mich freuen,
wenn ihr mir euer Vertrauen schenkt
und mich für Topf A empfehlt.
Danke.
Alle Bisherigen treten wieder an
und sind gesetzt.
Für eine reelle Chance
bräuchte Islam unbedingt
einen Listenplatz ganz vorne.
Platz 7 mit 191 Stimmen -
Islam Alijaj.
Hinteres Mittelfeld.
Mit dieser Wahlempfehlung hätte Islam
auch zu Hause bleiben können.
Überhaupt nicht.
Die Listengestaltung ...
Es wird sowieso schwierig,
einen Sitz zu gewinnen.
Und dass er eine Chance hat ...
Es gibt ja keine Rücktritte.
Aber das ist wichtig für uns,
für die Listengestaltung.
Wir können sagen,
dass wir auch für Inklusion stehen.
Die Menschen wissen das zwar,
aber es wird verstärkt,
wenn Islam das macht -
das ist super.
Aber man kann auch sagen,
dass er nur eine Chance hat,
wenn jemand wie Sie, jemand
von den Bisherigen verzichten würde.
(Lachend) So ein Blödsinn.
Die Enttäuschung
steht ihm ins Gesicht geschrieben.
Er hatte sich sehr viel mehr erhofft.
Islam, gratuliere.
Danke. Ich dir auch.
Wir machen einen coolen Wahlkampf.
- Unbedingt.
Aufgeben kennt Islam Alijaj nicht.
Nun will er das Feld
von ganz hinten aufrollen.
Gut.
David Mzee.
Tetraplegiker.
Bekannt als der Gelähmte,
der wieder gehen lernt.
Möglich machte es eine revolutionäre
Therapie mit Elektrostimulation,
entwickelt an der EPFL Lausanne.
Four, three, two, one.
Stop.
Die wiederkehrenden Tests
bei den Forschenden
sind für David eine Art Wettkampf.
Jedes Mal ist das Ziel:
schneller, weiter,
weniger Unterstützung,
tiefere Amplitude,
weniger Body weight support.
Ich bin Gordon.
- Freut mich, hallo.
Ich habe dich im Fernsehen gesehen
und ich habe über dich gelesen.
Und so habe ich mir gedacht:
Ich will dasselbe machen.
Cool.
- Es sieht grossartig aus.
Du inspirierst viele Leute.
Die meisten haben dich gesehen
und melden sich deswegen, weil
sie an der Studie teilnehmen wollen.
Vom Rollstuhl auf die Füsse.
Das ist kein medizinisches Wunder,
aber sehr wohl eine Sensation.
Als sie vor drei Jahren
öffentlich wurde,
ging die unglaubliche Story
um die Welt.
I did front flips.
It went well, two or three times.
The tragic affliction
of spinal cord injury.
These small steps
are huge ones for David Mzee
who was told
he would never walk again.
Ein Unfall vor zehn Jahren veränderte
auf einen Schlag sein Leben:
ein missglückter Dreifachsalto
während des Sportstudiums.
David ist gelähmt, das Rückenmark
aber nicht komplett durchtrennt.
2016 werden ihm am oberen Rückenmark
Elektroden implantiert,
die elektrische Impulse
an die Muskeln senden.
Es funktioniert.
David gewinnt Teile
seiner Bewegungsfähigkeit zurück.
Die Elektroden erledigen ihren Job,
den Rest muss das Gehirn übernehmen.
Nach fünf Monaten Reha
sind Kopf und Beine wieder vernetzt.
Bislang kannte Davids Leistungskurve
bei den Tests in Lausanne
nur eine Richtung: nach oben.
Wieder gehen können:
Es ist das Ziel und ein Traum,
aber keine Utopie mehr.
Der Blick geht sehr weit nach vorne.
Was mir dabei in den Sinn kommt,
ist freihändig zu gehen.
Ohne Rollator, ohne Barren,
ohne irgendwas.
Und das ...
Das braucht noch sehr viel.
Dazwischen gibt es fast nichts mehr.
Man kann noch schneller
und sicherer werden,
aber eine Gamechanger
ist das freihändige Gehen.
Einwärmen für die Tests im Ganglabor.
Seine Aufgabe:
freies Gehen mit Elektrostimulation.
Eine Aufhängung
hält ihn mit max. 65 kg,
seinem eigenen Körpergewicht.
Je weniger Support von oben,
desto schwieriger das Gehen.
Die Impulsgebung wird von
den Forschenden laufend angepasst.
Es kommt langsam.
Jetzt kommt die Rekordjagd.
Wir gehen tiefer mit der Entlastung.
Die Hälfte des Körpergewichts ist
entlastet, jetzt gehen wir tiefer.
Bereit?
- Ready.
Stimo an!
Okay, gehen wir runter.
Bleiben wir im Stairs Mode.
Gut.
Okay, gehen wir tiefer.
30.
Tiefer.
- 25.
- 20.
Okay, tiefer.
- 15.
Geh runter.
- 10.
Das ist das Minimum.
Nimm den Stairs Mode raus.
Rausnehmen.
- Okay.
Two, three,
four, five,
six, seven,
eight, nine ...
Whoo!
* Applaus *
Stairs mode was off, right?
- Congratulations.
Jetzt hat es
nur noch 10 kg hochgezogen.
Zehn Schritte
ist unser internes Mass.
Mit zehn Schritten hat man es
geschafft, sonst zählt es nicht.
Ich hatte Angst, dass der Stuhl
im Weg steht, aber es zählt.
Sie sagte,
dass sei Walking Mode gewesen,
also keine Seitenstabilisierung.
Sauberer Rekord.
Ich mache hell.
Guten Morgen, Amir.
So, frisch und munter?
Ich habe nicht so gut geschlafen
- Ich habe es gemerkt.
Unruhig gepennt.
Ein schlechte Nacht - wie so oft.
Die Muskelkrankheit
zehrt an Amirs Kräften.
Machen wir uns bereit.
Das brennt mega.
- Die Augen?
Ganz trocken.
Amir Gashi lebt seit ein paar Jahren
in der eigenen Wohnung.
Das ist möglich dank Betreuern
wie Yves Mayer.
Die beiden
sind ein eingespieltes Team.
* Elektronisches Piepen *
Okay. Nein, nicht okay.
Mach dich mal nützlich.
- Ja, ja.
Du könntest auch mal etwas machen,
nicht?
Die ganze Zeit nur rumliegen!
Okay.
Bereit, wenn Sie es sind.
Du kannst es ausschalten.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Amir ist 26,
seine statistische Lebenserwartung
etwa 35.
Jeden Tag stellt er sich
der fortschreitenden Krankheit
und der Tatsache,
dass er kein langes Leben haben wird.
Die Gedanken
kreisen auch um Leben und Tod.
Gerade wenn man mal krank ist,
weiss man nie,
ob es wieder gut wird.
Aber ich versuche ...
... einen glücklichen Lebensstil
zu haben.
Für Freude zu sorgen,
auch wenn ich mal traurig bin.
Ich versuche, mich abzulenken.
Manchmal muss man das einfach tun.
Zuerst rühren, rühren, rühren.
- Ist gut, danke.
Ein bisschen mehr. Gut.
Eine eigene Wohnung
statt ein Leben im Heim braucht Mut -
und Hilfe fast rund um die Uhr.
Yves Mayer
ist einer von drei Betreuern,
die den schwierigen Alltag
mit ihm teilen.
Weit mehr als nur ein Job.
Man ist einfach eng aufeinander,
sieht auch vieles.
Oft ist es auch ein intimer Job.
Daraus ergibt sich automatisch
eine engere Bindung.
Nähe und Distanz ist
in der Pädagogik immer ein Thema.
Das ist bei Amir und mir
definitiv nicht mehr so.
Wir sind vielmehr wie zwei Freunde.
Selbstbestimmt leben.
Amir hat sich
diese Freiheit erkämpft.
Welche Kosten die IV übernimmt,
ist ein Dauerthema,
obwohl es teurer käme,
wenn Amir in einem Heim leben würde.
Ich war in einem Heim.
Es war eine schöne Zeit dort.
Aber es lässt sich nicht damit
vergleichen, alleine zu wohnen.
Es ist zwar ein Aufwand für mich,
weil ich die Finanzen
im Griff haben muss,
ich muss planen,
mit den Leuten gut auskommen.
Wenn jemand ausfällt,
muss ich jemanden suchen.
Das ist nicht immer einfach,
aber es ist ein Vorteil für mich,
weil ich jeden Tag so leben kann,
wie ich will.
Das ist sehr wertvoll.
Hier hinten?
- Ja.
* Schwungvolle elektronische Klänge *
Die Tage
verbringt er in seinem Studio.
Wir haben dem Soundtüftler
unsere Filmaufnahmen mitgebracht.
Er kombiniert die Bilder
sofort mit fetten Beats.
* Regelmässige Bässe *
Noch mehr Tiefe.
- Weisst du, wie ich es meine?
Mit der Frequenz von vorher,
so wie er läuft,
das ist noch witzig.
* Melodiesegmente setzen ein. *
Aus der spontanen Spielerei
wird ein Projekt.
DJ DFKT X macht sich an die Arbeit -
er komponiert und arrangiert
die Musik zu diesem Film.
* Lounge-Klänge mit tiefem Bass *
High Noon in Zürich.
Für Islam Alijaj
geht es heute um alles oder nichts.
Die Parteidelegierten
bestimmen ihre Nationalratsliste.
Für eine Wahlchance im Herbst
benötigt Islam wenigstens Platz 18,
den letzten im Topf A.
Empfohlen ist er für Topf B
und Platz 24.
Um es noch nach vorne zu schaffen,
braucht er heute ein kleines Wunder.
Wer dem zustimmen kann,
erhebe bitte die Stimmkarte.
Die Delegierten bestätigen Namen und
Plätze in Topf A ohne Gegenanträge.
Das war es wohl für Islam,
der Mist scheint geführt.
Genossinnen und Genossen,
wir bereinigen den Topf B.
Das sind weitere Personen,
die sich für die Nationalratswahlen
zur Verfügung stellen.
Es wäre ein Zeichen
von Wertschätzung und Anstand,
wenn alle zuhören und abstimmen.
Danke.
* Applaus *
Vielen Dank.
D.h., Topf B bleibt unverändert,
wie ihr ihn
auf der Einladung bekommen habt.
Islam, gibt es einen Antrag,
dass du weiter nach oben kommst?
Willst du, dass einer gestellt wird?
Okay.
Ja.
Wir haben ... Willst du für ihn
einen Antrag stellen?
Habt ihr unterschiedliche Anträge?
Mega gerne.
- Auf Platz 18?
Ja.
Okay. Sag mir einfach noch mal,
wie ich es richtig sage - Handicap.
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
- Menschen mit Einschränkungen.
Mit Einschränkungen.
Sie gehen aufs Ganze,
aber ein neues Problem taucht auf.
Mit Rang 18 würde Islam
eine Frau und den Präsidenten
der Zürcher Stadtpartei verdrängen.
Es kommt zu Diskussionen
und einem Kompromiss.
Sollen wir Platz 20 sagen?
- Sagen wir 20.- Ja.
Wir sind so weit.
Dann übergebe ich das Mikrofon
an Qëndresa.
Ich möchte den Antrag stellen,
dass Islam von Platz 24
auf Platz 20 gesetzt wird.
Es ist für uns als Partei
ein grosser Pluspunkt,
wenn er sich mit seinem
Migrationshintergrund, seinem Wissen
und auch mit seinem Engagement
für Personen mit Beeinträchtigungen
einsetzt.
Das wäre
ein grosser Pluspunkt für uns.
Er hat es verdient,
etwas höher zu kommen.
Ich würde sagen,
wir kommen zur Abstimmung.
Wer dem Antrag, Islam auf Platz 20
zu setzen, zustimmen möchte,
soll es
mit dem Erheben der Karte bezeugen.
Sind wir so weit?
Gut. Gegenmehr?
Der Antrag wird
mit 74 zu 50 Stimmen abgelehnt.
Das bedeutet nach wie vor,
Topf B bleibt so, wie er
von der Personalkommission vorliegt.
Vier Reihen.
Die erste Hälfte der Liste vorne,
die anderen dahinter.
Also.
Islam wollte mehr als ein Foto.
Doch seine Partei scheint
nicht bereit für einen wie ihn.
Grenzen setzen ihr nur andere,
sie selbst kennt keine.
Etwas höher, genau.
Klettern in der Steilwand, mit einem
Sehrest von ein paar wenigen Prozent.
Super.
Bergsteigen - Barbara Müller tut es,
wie sie alles im Leben angeht:
unerschrocken und unglaublich zäh.
Ich habe keinen Tritt. Hilfe.
Auf Reibung.
- Ja.
Jetzt musst du einfach halten.
- Ja, ja.
Ihm vertraut sie blind.
Mit Bergführer Urs Steiner
klettert sie schon viele Jahre.
Etwas weiter. Sehr gut.
Dort ist ein roter Tritt,
mit dem linken Fuss.
Rot?
Er wäre tiefer gewesen,
aber macht nichts.
Sehr gut.
Ich bewege mich als Geologin
oft im Gebirge.
Das ist auch Training
für die Himalaja-Expeditionen.
Ich kann mit den Händen tasten.
Das regt das Tastgefühl an.
Als Geologin erst recht. Es ist ein
grosser Unterschied je nach Gestein.
Wie sehr kann ich
dem Gestein trauen?
Für mich ist es eine
sehr elegante Form der Fortbewegung.
Weil ich vieles nicht sehe,
kann ich mir mit den Händen helfen.
Urs Steiner
markiert die nächste Passage.
Grelle Farben
kann Barbara noch erkennen.
Ich markiere hier den Tritt.
Der Tritt ist darüber.
Dort, wo es grün ist.
Griff.
Die spürst du dann wohl.
- Die erkenne ich dann schon.
Ich komme langsam.
Taste dort.
Dort kommt eine Nase.
Siehst du es?
- Ja.
Ich stehe im Moment.
Die Kreidepunkte.
- Ich sehe sie vor meiner Nase.
Barbara klettert nicht nur zum Spass.
Sie braucht das Training
für ihr Hilfsprojekt
in ihrer zweiten Heimat Nepal.
Vom Himalaja-Gebirge gelangt
hochgiftiges Arsen ins Grundwasser,
das die lokale Bevölkerung
krank macht.
Die Einheimischen in den Ebenen
leiden überdurchschnittlich oft
an Tumoren und Krebs.
Das soll endlich ein Ende haben.
Die freie Forscherin kennt
Geologie und Verhältnisse in Nepal
wie kaum eine andere.
Manchmal streift sie wochenlang
mit befreundeten Sherpas
durch die Hochplateaus des Himalaja,
oft auf über 6'000 m.
Im Gebirge sammelt und analysiert
die Geochemikerin Gesteinsproben.
Und in den Ebenen versucht sie, das
verseuchte Wasser zu dekontaminieren.
Ein einfaches Filtersystem
aus Steinen und Nägeln soll helfen,
das giftige Arsen zu binden.
Das Geld für ihr Nepal-Projekt
aufzubringen, ist ein ewiger Kampf.
Aber kämpfen ist sie sich ja gewohnt.
* Seufzen *
Auch in der Felswand fightet
Barbara Müller um jeden Meter.
Ihre Kräfte scheinen nachzulassen.
Doch das sieht Barbara,
wie so oft, ein wenig anders.
Berge - sei es hier oder in Nepal -
sind die reinste Erholung.
Das ist Relaxen,
das ist entspannend.
Kein Streit
mit irgendwelchen Ämtern.
Kein Geld als Wissenschaftlerin
beschaffen müssen.
Hier oben ist man frei,
das ist ein Stück Freiheit.
Genau.
Sehr gut.
Oben hinstehen.
Ach.
Gratuliere.
- Gratuliere, super.
Will Islam Alijaj reisen,
nimmt er die SBB -
mit GA 1. Klasse und
Platzreservation im Niederflurwagen.
Wie so oft kommt es anders.
Wechsel des Rollmaterials,
unangekündigt.
Islam muss in den Käfig
und sich dann ohne Hilfe
zur Rollstuhlecke
in der zweiten Klasse manövrieren.
* Helle gläserne Musik*
Islam im Bundeshaus -
als Tourist nicht als Politiker.
Eins.
Hier lang?
- Auf diese Seite.
(Lift) Erstes Obergeschoss.
Premier étage.
Islam Alijaj holte bei den Wahlen
fast 63'000 Stimmen.
Praktisch ohne Wahlkampf,
trotz schlechtem Listenplatz
und obwohl ihn über 8'000 Genossinnen
und Genossen von der Liste strichen.
14'000 Stimmen mehr und er wäre
heute als Nationalrat der SP hier.
* Dynamische Musik *
Okay, stoppt kurz!
Zuhören! Das Ganze
ist noch nicht so dynamisch.
Sie zeigen mit dem Stock an,
wo Sie den Ball wollen.
Wer steht, kann mit dem Bein
einen Schritt zurückgehen
und den Ball schön leise annehmen.
Und genauso
spielen Sie ihn wieder ab. Klar?
Für David Mzee zählt nur, was geht,
und nie, was nicht geht.
Mit diesem Selbstverständnis
hat er seinen neuen Job gekriegt.
Es ist sein erster Schultag
als Sportlehrer - in Festanstellung.
Bei mir gibt es kein Punkte.
Für David war schon immer klar:
Dieser Beruf
ist auch im Rollstuhl möglich.
Für mich ist vieles
tatsächlich selbstverständlich.
Dann höre ich andere sagen,
wie besonders das sei,
und es fällt mir wieder auf.
Aber für mich
ist es selbstverständlich,
und deshalb wirkt es wohl auch so.
Das Handicap
konnte ihn nicht stoppen.
Nach seinem Unfall
kehrte er an die ETH zurück
und schloss sein Sportstudium ab -
als Jahrgangsbester.
Als sich David für eine Aushilfs-
stelle am KV Wetzikon meldete,
war der damalige Rektor
zuerst perplex.
Ich fand ihn sehr sympathisch, aber
hielt es für absolut nicht machbar,
dass jemand,
der nicht alles vorzeigen kann,
in der Halle steht.
Ich sagte zu Dave:
"Ich bin ganz ehrlich mit dir
und politisch nicht ganz korrekt
und sage,
dass es nicht denkbar ist."
Zum Glück habe ich diese
konventionellen Denkmuster verlassen
und gedacht,
dass wir es mal probieren.
Heute sehe ich das Resultat,
ich höre die Resonanz der Schüler
und von Lehrbetrieben,
und sie ist einhellig positiv.
Zuhören!
Entweder schaffen wir es,
dass vier auf dem Feld sind
und wir spielen können
oder wir machen Liniensprints.
Was wollen Sie?
Weiter geht's!
Sportlehrer im Rollstuhl.
Tetraplegiker,
der wieder gehen lernt.
David Mzee ist keine Hürde zu hoch.
Trotz Handicap
scheint ihm alles zu gelingen.
Wieso ihm -
den meisten andern aber nicht?
Ich hatte bis zum Unfall
ein relativ normales Leben.
Insofern habe ich vieles erlebt,
das ich nicht erlebt hätte,
wäre ich von Anfang an
im Rollstuhl gewesen.
Für mich war es gut, dass ich in
der Pubertät nicht im Rollstuhl war,
dass kein Mitleid da war.
Dann wird man etwas anders behandelt
und man entwickelt sich anders.
Ich denke gerade an jemanden,
der auch schon sagte,
er hätte sich während seiner Jugend
etwas mehr Druck gewünscht
oder dass ihm etwas mehr
Verantwortung übergeben worden wäre.
Insofern
hat das für mich so gestimmt,
obwohl ich es mir
auch nicht ausgesucht hatte.
Aber wenn du nach dem Unterschied
fragst: Vielleicht ist das einer.
* Drollig-fröhlicher Elektrobeat *
Ihr könnt zusammenkommen.
Das war noch ein Unentschieden?
Zwei, ja. Ihr wart zwei hinten?
Wow, okay!
Nach Monaten
treffen wir Amir Gashi wieder.
Der DJ tüftelt an den letzten Beats
für diesen Film.
Die Folgen der Krankheit
sind schlimmer geworden.
Freund Livio steuert die Regler, die
Amir nicht mehr selbst bedienen kann.
Der zweite.
* Livio spricht unverständlich. *
Der ist genial.
Ich weiss. Aber was müssen wir uns
anhören, bis wir dort sind?
Das ist auch megaschön.
Amir will es nicht schönreden:
Das Corona-Jahr hat ihm zugesetzt.
Es ist sicher blöd,
v.a. in meiner Situation,
weil ich quasi ein Jahr weniger habe
und eh schon weniger habe.
Aber ich habe wirklich mehr auf mich
geschaut in den eineinhalb Jahren,
also dass es mir
seelisch und psychisch gut geht.
Körperlich war es schwierig.
Aber was ihn mehr schmerzt,
ist das Jahr ohne Auftritte als DJ.
Mach auf.
Soll ich?
- Drei, zwei, eins, gut.
Vielleicht mal
den dramatischen Synthi noch raus.
Im zweiten Jahr von Corona hat "DOK"
auch David Mzee wieder getroffen.
Selbst die Pandemie
konnte ihn nicht bremsen.
David bleibt auf der Überholspur und
macht beim Gehen weiter Fortschritte.
Inzwischen hat sich
ein weiterer Traum erfüllt.
Seine Partnerin Janine und David
sind Eltern geworden.
Zu Papi gehen?
Willst du zu Papi? Hoi. Hoi.
Ja. Gell, ist viel zu hell.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich mir
extra unmögliche Ziele suche
und mich da dann,
komme was wolle, voll reinlege.
Es ergibt sich meistens.
Es war mit der Studie in Lausanne so
und auch mit dem Job.
Ich habe mir das
nicht direkt ausgesucht.
Irgendwo ging eine Tür auf
und ich ging durch.
Ich bin selbst gespannt,
welche nächste grosse Tür ich öffne.
Yves, was meinst du?
Nicht schlecht. Höre ich
auch zum ersten Mal so. Ist gut.
V.a. vorher fand ich es mal gut,
als doch noch etwas Bass drin war.
Das fand ich schön.
Langsam, aber doch etwas ...
Amir hat dramatisch Gewicht verloren.
Er möchte essen,
hat aber Mühe beim Schlucken.
Am meisten Energie kostet ihn jedoch
der Stress mit der IV.
Wegen der Finanzierung
für Mehrbetreuung, die Amir braucht.
Er will das Recht auf
selbstbestimmtes Leben - mehr nicht.
Mein Fall ist ein schwerer Fall.
Viele andere haben mehr Kraft
als ich und machen es nicht.
Das ist schon schade.
Es ist immer ein Kampf.
Inklusion ist etwas, das wir
nicht zu oft erwähnen sollten.
Wir sollten es mehr leben.
Barbara Müller ist im Hoch.
Dass Arsen hoch giftig ist, habt ihr
ja schon mehrere Male erfahren.
Sie ist Gastdozentin
an der Uni Basel.
Ihre Vorlesungen
hält sie wegen Corona online ab.
Damit aber nicht genug:
Ihr gelingt die Wiederwahl
in den Thurgauer Kantonsrat.
Und auch der Dauerstreit mit der IV
ist definitiv vorbei.
... solche Vergiftungserscheinungen
zeigen.
Fast das Wichtigste im Moment
für sie:
Sie kann endlich wieder
nach Nepal einreisen
und ihr Hilfsprojekt weiterführen.
Die inzwischen fast blinde Geologin
hat zwar einiges erreicht.
Doch ihr Kampf geht weiter, bis die
Inklusion von Menschen mit Handicap
kein leeres Versprechen mehr ist.
Es  i s t  ein Märchen.
Da müsste sich in den Köpfen
so viel ändern, dass ich mich frage,
wie lang das wohl dauern würde.
In dem Sinn haben wir
wenig erreicht, sehr wenig.
Aber solange man versucht, Menschen
mit Behinderungen auszuschliessen,
und sie ihre Fähigkeiten nicht
ausleben lässt, sehe ich schwarz.
Man sagt, dass Sieger da aufstehen,
wo Verlierer liegen bleiben.
Islam Alijaj hat sein Feuer
nach dem grandiosen Scheitern
bei den Wahlen nicht verloren.
Im Gegenteil.
Zusammen mit fünf Mitarbeiterinnen
lanciert er ein neues Projekt:
das Ability Center.
Die Anlaufstelle soll helfen,
Projektideen von Menschen
mit Behinderungen umzusetzen:
rascher und v.a. zahlreicher.
In die Offensive gehen, damit
Inklusion in Politik und Gesellschaft
kein Lippenbekenntnis mehr bleibt.
Islam Alijaj und sein Team
wollen neue Tatsachen schaffen.
Alles andere ist keine Option.
Cheers!
- Zum Wohl.
* Lockere, elektronische Klänge *
Wow.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
M. Hoss, A. Duttweiler,
L. Zbinden - 2021